Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
Plus que jamais, nous manquons de temps.
Je suis sûre que dans cette salle,
chacun a un emploi du temps très calé.
Mais qu’est-ce qu’il se passe
lorsqu’un événement extérieur
pointe le bout de son nez
et que notre programme
chavire en un instant ?
Ça peut être une nouvelle rencontre,
un nouveau job,
un burn-out ou une maladie,
qui nous bouleverse.
Pour moi, cet événement a été
la naissance de ma première fille.
J'étais devenue vulnérable et je croyais
que mon rôle était de tout assumer.
J’étais à la disposition totale
de ma fille.
Au moindre cri,
elle était déjà dans mes bras.
À table, plus de repas chauds pour moi.
J’avais une patience
et une créativité inouïes
jusqu’à ce qu’elle mange
sa dernière cuillère.
Et alors que je croyais
que tout était sous contrôle,
voilà un deuxième qui arrive.
Et là, ça casse.
Je ne contrôlais plus rien.
La fatigue et le sentiment de solitude
m’ont fait perdre confiance
et la colère a pris place.
Et quoi de plus facile que de s’en
prendre à ces petits êtres sans défense ?
Vous voyez, mes parents et mon entourage
m'ont transmis tout leur amour.
Mais leurs peurs et leurs blessures
avaient aussi déteint sur moi.
Et me voilà à mon tour
passer le relais à mes enfants.
Je tiens comme ça pendant six ans,
puis je décide de trouver des solutions
afin de pouvoir garder l’amour
et calmer ma colère qui, au fond,
cachait une peur énorme de l’inconnu.
Je fais mes recherches et je tombe
sur une formation Montessori
qui, comme par hasard,
commençait à ce moment-là.
Et là, c’est un feu d’artifice
de découvertes.
C’était un endroit où l’on voyait le monde
à la hauteur et au rythme
d’un enfant de trois à six ans.
C'était une incroyable révolution.
J'ai appris les lois qui régissent
le développement de tout enfant.
C’était vraiment une telle passion
que j’en perds mes mots.
Je change de métier
et je deviens éducatrice.
Vous devez vous dire
que j’ai trouvé les solutions
pour devenir une maman formidable.
Figurez-vous que pas du tout.
C’était pire.
Le matin, je travaillais à l’école,
l’après-midi, j’allais en formation.
Entre les deux, je ramenais le matériel
mathématique à la maison,
je l’installais et j’ordonnais
avec une voix toute douce
à ma fille de quatre ans de venir et de me
montrer où se trouvaient le 1, le 5, le 8.
Elle me regardait
avec des yeux grand ouverts,
sans comprendre ce qui m’avait piquée
et faisait tout pour me faire plaisir,
car elle comprenait
que l’heure était grave.
Entre la théorie et la pratique,
il y a du chemin,
et ce chemin est long.
Avec l’expérience en classe, mes enfants
plus grands, j’ai vu plus clair
et j’ai pris de la distance.
La première leçon que j’ai retenue,
c’est que pour avancer,
la clé, c’est l’observation.
Et nous avons un guide.
Ce guide, c'est l'enfant.
Grâce à l’observation,
nous pouvons prendre conscience
de qui on a en face de nous.
En lui donnant du temps et de l’espace,
il peut dévoiler sa personnalité
et son potentiel.
La deuxième leçon que j’en ai tirée,
c’est que l’enfant a besoin
de trois libertés fondamentales.
Mais attention !
Ces libertés demandent un environnement
adapté et un adulte préparé,
car nous sommes
comme les rives d’un fleuve
qui permettent à l’enfant
d’avancer librement vers son but.
Quelles sont ces libertés ?
La première des libertés,
c’est la liberté de mouvement.
Tout est mouvement dans notre monde.
Nous avons tous une pulsion
qui nous anime et qui nous est propre.
Chacun a sa propre façon
d’apprendre à marcher et de marcher.
Il a sa propre façon
d’apprendre à écrire et d’écrire.
Quand j’étais petite,
je vivais avec des femmes,
ma mère, ma grand-mère et mes tantes.
Une de mes pulsions
était de passer le balai.
C’était comme une communion avec cet
objet-là et je pouvais passer des heures.
Mais il y en avait toujours une qui
me disait que je ne le faisais pas bien
et qu’il fallait le faire plus vite.
Mais ce n’était pas bien grave parce que
j’attendais le moment de la sieste
pour retrouver la liberté de danser
avec mon balai.
Mais pour un enfant de trois ans,
c’est un petit peu plus embêtant,
car tout faire à sa place
brise sa motivation personnelle.
Plus un enfant a la liberté du mouvement,
plus ses mouvements deviennent précis,
plus il a confiance en lui
et plus il devient indépendant.
D’ailleurs, n’est-ce pas le but de
chacun que de devenir autonome ?
Lorsque j’étais à l’école,
ce qui m’a beaucoup intriguée,
c’est que les enfants avaient
une joie folle à s’habiller seuls ;
certains aidaient même
ceux qui n’y arrivaient pas.
Et lorsque leurs parents arrivaient,
ils se transformaient en mollusques
et ne mettaient même pas
une chaussure seuls.
La deuxième des libertés,
c’est celle de s’exprimer.
Le langage est propre à l’homme,
mais il n’est pas inné.
C’est une conquête.
Plus on donne des opportunités
à l’enfant de s’exprimer,
plus son langage devient précis,
plus il a confiance en lui,
et plus il est indépendant.
À l’école, lorsqu’on accueille les enfants
accompagnés de leurs parents
et qu’on leur pose la question :
« Qu’est-ce que tu as mangé ce matin ? »,
qui répond ?
À peine l’information arrive
dans le cerveau de l’enfant
qu’il entend déjà la réponse
que donne son parent à sa place.
Eh oui, le système neuronal d’un adulte
est bien plus performant
que celui d’un enfant.
Peut-être tellement performant
qu’il n’arrive même pas
à s’empêcher de parler.
Cette liberté d’expression
doit aussi être en équilibre
avec la capacité de l’adulte à écouter.
Prendre conscience de cet équilibre
m’a permis
d’apprendre des secrets d’enfants
qui ont enrichi mon expérience et ma vie.
Donc on a la première des libertés
qui est celle du mouvement,
la deuxième des libertés
qui est celle de s’exprimer.
La troisième des libertés,
c’est la liberté de choisir.
Évidemment, à deux ans, on ne va pas
lui laisser le choix de son école.
Mais est-ce que vous savez qu’un
nouveau-né peut choisir de manger ou pas ?
À la maison, un des plus grands
moments de tension
était lorsque mes filles
devaient choisir leurs habits.
Cette tension s’est tout de suite dissipée
lorsque j’ai introduit
des choix simples et adaptés comme :
« Est-ce que tu veux mettre un tee-shirt
bleu ou un tee-shirt jaune ? »
« Est-ce que tu veux manger une pomme
ou est-ce que tu veux
manger une banane ? »
Finalement, ce n’était pas
la question qui était compliquée.
C’était au moment
où ma fille changeait d’avis,
au moment où on va pour croquer la pomme,
elle nous regarde avec un air angélique,
la banane dans la main,
et qu’elle nous dit :
« Je veux la pomme. »
Lorsque j’ai tenu bon
comme les rives d’un fleuve,
j’ai vu le fruit de mon travail
le lendemain.
Ma fille a réfléchi
deux fois avant de choisir.
Plus un enfant a des opportunités
de choisir, plus sa volonté se développe,
plus il a confiance en ses choix,
plus il devient
indépendant et responsable.
Ces libertés m’ont permis d’apprendre
quelque chose de très important :
grâce à ces libertés, j’ai découvert
que cet enfant était
profondément philosophique.
Il m’a apporté une théorie du monde
que je peux appliquer n’importe où,
avec n’importe qui.
Ces libertés ont donné place à
des moments de partage, à des fous rires,
et la spontanéité est entrée
dans notre vie.
Grâce à mes formations, mes lectures
et mes expériences,
j’ai découvert que cette petite créature
qui choisissait de manger ou pas
était profondément philosophique.
Chacun met dans la naissance de son enfant
ses ambitions, ses fantasmes, ses idéaux.
Et si nous laissions nos enfants
s’épanouir en respectant ces libertés,
et ainsi nous réserver des surprises
encore plus grandes
que celles que nous pouvions
nous imaginer ?
Je suis consciente que tous les parents
n’ont pas le même enthousiasme
dans leur enfant et son éducation,
mais l’enfant vient au monde
pour une raison,
peut-être celle de prendre le relais
et de courir plus vite,
ou peut-être pour ralentir.
(Applaudissements)